Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now visibly panicking
about not only the existing arrests that already
took place, but about possible forthcoming
arrests.
And he has declared that Joe Biden is guilty
and another one of these sick orange swollen
videos with the bizarre lighting in this clip.
Donald Trump attacks the special prosecutor,
Jack Smith, as a lunatic and says that Biden
is guilty.
Not exactly law and order.
Is it to say someone who hasn't even been
charged or there's no evidence that Biden's
guilty of anything?
He's no, he he's guilty.
Speaker 5: Trump hating prosecutor Jack Smith,
a lunatic should go get Biden for what he
did.
He's very guilty.
Very.
Speaker 1: Biden is not just guilty.
He's very, very guilty.
And this is, of course, another example of
what I spoke to you about on, jeez, was it
Tuesday or Wednesday?
The abandonment of their own stated principles
by Republicans were about law and order and
due process.
Are you, though, because you want the January
six rioters to get special treatment?
You want Hillary and you want Biden and you
want Obama locked up, even though they haven't
even been charged with any crimes and you're
now declaring people guilty, of course, without
ever explaining what crimes you even think
they committed.
When people ask Trump what?
What is Obama gate anyway?
He says, You know what it is?
It's the biggest political crime of the century.
Oh yeah, but like what laws were violated?
Now that's that's fake news.
That question is fake news.
This entire thing continuing with Donald Trump
going through his typical grievances, including
that every investigation of him is a scam.
Speaker 5: 80% of the public think that if
former President Donald J. Trump me is being
treated very unfairly for political reasons
and due to the fact that he is leading in
all of the polls.
Speaker 1: I love this third person stuff
he Trump is leading.
Speaker 5: 80% of the people agree with that.
I say these prosecutorial scams are hoaxes
are all about election interference and Republican
leadership must get tough and must be smart.
But we're not going to have a country left.
Speaker 1: Yep, there will be no country left
if Trump is.
Held accountable for the things he allegedly
did.
Trump then Trump furious, I guess now with
Republicans who don't like him or continuing
to be furious, he actually tells people, if
you turn on the TV, even if you're watching
Fox News, if you see Karl Rove there or Bill
Barr or Paul Ryan, you've got to turn that
TV off.
Speaker 5: You see writers Karl Rove, Bill
Barr or Paul Ryan on your television screen.
Just turn to a different station or turn it
off.
Turn off that set as fast as you can.
You're frankly better off watching Democrats.
They are the worse.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So this is basically I don't want you to hear
any of the things that some Republicans are
saying about me because not every Republican
likes me.
So just turn the TV off.
Kind of treating his followers like little
children.
Just don't even let them watch it.
Don't let them think for themselves.
Trump then, going back to his obsession about
Chinese restaurants and Chinatown when it
comes to documents, when.
Speaker 5: Will they be looking at the Biden
documents, many of which were brought in from
Chinatown and then sent to Boston?
Is this why China paid him and Hunter millions
and millions of dollars?
Speaker 1: Now, many of you are wondering
what the hell is Trump talking about?
Chinatown.
Trump seized on some story whose details I
previously researched and sort of escape me
now, where there was a period during which
the during which NARA, the National Archives,
was temporarily storing some documents, I
believe, for a presidential library in a building
that previously housed a laundry and also
a Chinese restaurant, if I recall correctly.
And now it's about Chinatown.
And it's it's just insanity that this is still
something Trump is focusing on.
And then, of course, lastly, this is a common
way that Trump wrap speeches declaring himself
the most honest person ever anywhere, not
just among American presidents, but just anywhere.
Speaker 5: After eight years of various politically
motivated investigations, hoaxers, scams and
witch hunts.
This must make me the most honest and honorable
man anywhere in the world must.
Nobody in history has ever been through the
scrutiny that I have.
We're going to make America great again.
We are going to get rid of these lunatics.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Well, we.
I am all for getting rid of lunatics.
That is absolutely the case.
So what is causing Trump to be triggered in
this way?
It's actually not completely clear.
So let's go through it.
If you look at polling, the polling is like
not great for Trump in the general, but it's
very good in the primary.
We look at recent general election polls.
We've got a YouGov economist poll, a B-plus
rated poll, which was released two days ago.
Biden versus Trump.
This one has Trump up one among registered
voters and it has Trump up four among.
What is the I actually don't remember what
the F stands for.
Is this all voters registered?
I'm not sure what that is.
A. Okay.
There is an earlier YouGov poll sponsored
by Yahoo News, which has Trump up to over
Joe Biden, but with only something like 70%
of respondents choosing one or the other.
Biden versus Trump in a morning consult poll,
it's Biden plus three.
Okay.
So like it's roughly even with Biden, you
could say if you then look at Republican primary
polls, Trump is just crushing.
I mean, again, as I said before, unless something
really changes, unless DeSantis enters this
race with some kind of blockbuster and something
terrible happens to Donald Trump, I don't
see how DeSantis is going to be the guy to
beat him.
In a new YouGov poll, Trump is ahead of DeSantis
by 22.
In a Yahoo News YouGov poll, Trump is ahead
of DeSantis by 24.
University of New Hampshire poll for the New
Hampshire primary, Trump leads by 20.
It.
It's really very strong for Donald Trump.
So is the polling the reason that Trump is
flipping out doesn't seem to be.
Is it that Donald Trump is catching wind that
actually being under indictment in New York
already and potentially more forthcoming indictments
are really going to get in the way of him
being able to run the campaign?
He wants to run it when he wants to do more
rallies and the entire thing.
That could be And in fact, there have been
rumors that by the end of this month, April,
although at this point it doesn't it's not
clear it's going to happen.
There were rumors that Trump's second arrest
was going to take place in the last week of
April.
Maybe Trump has caught wind of that.
It's not really clear.
And then thirdly is there is something going
on in terms of fundraising and big donors
where Trump is quietly hearing that there
are big donors he would like to have in his
corner who are.
Going to either wait or go to SanDisk or someone
else.
It's a total hypothetical.
And again, we are not seeing evidence of that.
In fact, at the top of the show today, I told
you about the reality that many DeSantis would
be mega-donors are furious with him and saying,
what the hell is he doing leaving Florida
when there's flooding in gas lines?
I'm not going to donate to Santos.
So that also doesn't seem to be the reason
that Trump would be so triggered.
We don't actually know the answer.
And I think one of the things we have to come
to terms with is that with Donald Trump, there
is often no obvious explanation for his erratic
behavior.
After the break, I am briefly going to talk
to you about a more specific sort of kerfuffle
that came out of this video, which is Trump's
much more direct focus on Ron DeSantis, which
has a lot of interesting things underlying
it.
We'll get to that after the break